For the Muslims that are going to come
up, I want you guys to know you are
embarrassing yourselves. You're
embarrassing Islam. Rightfully so.
They're like, "This is what Islam does
to you." But I'm just saying we don't
we're not doing it. We're not making fun
of you. We're not trapping you. This is
what you're doing to yourselves. So the
Torah, Gospel, and Psalms are Islamic
scriptures, and they're corrupted. So
you have corrupted scripture in Islam.
Correct.
>> Yeah. Based on what I said, then it's
true. Yeah. Awesome. You said that the
reason why you wouldn't trust a religion
that has corrupted scripture is because
it wouldn't be from God. You also
acknowledged that Islam contains
corrupted scripture. So therefore, by
your own logic and the conclusion is is
that because Islam has corrupted
scripture within it, therefore Islam is
not from God. Right?
>> So we're talking about scriptures. So if
I were to say that anything corrupted
does not come from God, that would mean
that the Bible, the Psalm, and the Torah
have been corrupted and the Quran has
not been corrupted. So the word of God
being the Quran is not corrupted. So
Islam is not an untrustworthy religion
because we follow the Quran.
>> Let me let me let me just ask you the
same question. Is the Torah corrupted?
>> Sorry. Go ahead and ask me again.
>> Yeah. Has the Torah been corrupt?
>> What is happening, bro? Okay. So, would
you follow a religion with corrupted
scripture?
>> No, definitely not.
>> All right. How many sets of scriptures
did your god reveal? Before the Quran.
>> Three before the Quran.
>> Three before the Quran. Cool. What
happened to them?
>> It got corrupted.
>> Cool. So, you do follow religion with
corrupted scripture.
>> No, we dropped those three corrupt
corrupted scriptures. They're not part
of our
>> because those three scriptures were
what?
>> Corrupted.
>> And they were whose scriptures?
>> Our scriptures were dead.
>> So your script
>> Yeah, but we don't use them anymore.
>> I can't, bro. So in your religion, you
do have corrupted scriptures.
>> We had corrupted scriptures. We don't
them anymore.
>> Get off my stage, you numb digger. So
earlier you said you wouldn't follow a
religion with corrupted scriptures. Can
you switch that now and say you do
follow a religion with corrupted
scriptures? And on top of that the
majority of your scriptures in your
religion are corrupted. But within your
religion
>> say within your religion cuz it's not
part they were built upon my religion.
>> Are these Did Allah reveal Did Allah
reveal the scriptures?
>> Yes. So are they Allah's scriptures?
Okay. So are they Allah's scriptures?
>> Yes. revealed to prophets
>> under the religion of Islam, right?
>> Um, sure.
>> Okay. So, these are your religious
scriptures within Islam that have been
corrupted. So, the majority of your
scriptures revealed in your religion
have been corrupted. So, please be
honest. You do follow a religion with
corrupted scripture.
>> Sorry, we're just just cleaning up
around
>> like these are these are these these are
the same people that are getting
>> we're just helping you clean it up a
bit.
>> Oh, logic. Huh? Logic. Oh, throw that in
here. There we go.
>> There we go. You got it. You got it.
>> I got it. I got it. Good. Good.
>> So, no, I we got you. So, according to
everything you laid out, the Quran is
the only book that Allah promised to
preserve. His other books, he allowed
them to get corrupted. He didn't promise
to preserve those. So, he has a track
record of letting his books get
corrupted except for one. Is that right?
>> Yeah. But also, it comes with common
sense that people memorize them.
>> I got you.
>> But here's basically the thing. Okay.
>> So, this would be the original thing.
This would be the original book that
available with them. This would part
beings. So when the prophet comes to
confirm, right? He's confirming what
they have that's actually legitimate. So
when the prophet comes and says for
example 1 2 3 six, right? He's not
saying any four and five. You know what
else they might have with them? They
might have camels. They might have
sandals. They have so many other things.
>> So if I were to say, hey, that sticky
note that you have, that sticky note
that's with you, I'm confirming it. So
does that include all six sentences?
Well, here's the point that I'm making
though, right?
>> Is the sticky note with
>> Yeah, I have it right now.
>> Okay. So, if I say I'm confirming the
sticky note with you, that includes
those two corrupted lines on the sticky
note, right?
>> What does the verse say?
>> Confirming what is with them.
>> Confirming what is with them. You know
what else is with me? A cup of soup.
>> It's talking about It's talking about
the scriptures, bro. It's talking about
the scriptures.
>> It's talking about what they have with
Right. But there's a lot of things that
could be Muhammad. I need you to I need
you to focus here cuz if I say that I'm
confirming that sticky note with you,
does that include all six lines on that
sticky note?
>> No.
>> If you're confirming the sticky note
with me, if you're saying you're
confirming the sticky note with me, then
it'll be all six lines.
>> Exactly. So, unfortunately though with
that statement, I'm confirming even
those two corrupted lines on that sticky
note. Right.
>> It's confirming. But again, I now I feel
like we're going in circles again.
Right. Answer
>> once more. And look, this is where this
is where we have in the Quran. It talks
about it too, right?
>> You got to answer, bro. Please.
>> No, because I I am answering you. I told
you when you say I'm confirming that
sticky note, you're saying this to me,
right, in this conversation. Absolutely.
>> So that so that means that that means
that I just confirmed even the two
corrupted lines in that sticky note,
right?
>> The two corrupted lines. But the point
that I'm trying to make here, so let me
just make a point real quick. Okay.
if you can deal with this cuz this is in
this is crucial. Dude,
>> this is what this topic do to them, bro.
>> You get you get you get some of the most
confusing answers and you just let them
talk and you just be like, "Do you hear
yourself?" And apparently they don't cuz
they don't even they can't even repeat
what they said 10 seconds ago.
>> Would you follow a religion with
corrupted scripture?
>> No. That's what you guys are for.
>> Okay. You said no, you wouldn't. Uh, is
the Torah are the Torah, Psalms, and
Gospel Islamic scriptures?
>> They were. Yes.
>> What happened to them?
>> They got corrupted by you guys.
>> So, Islam has corrupted scripture. So,
therefore, it's untrustworthy. Is the
Torah a Christian book or an Islamic
book? Yep.
>> Yeah. The original Torah is Islamic
book, but not this version. No.
>> The Psalms. Is that a Christian book or
an Islamic book?
>> The original book. Yes.
>> The Gospel. Is that an Islamic book or a
Christian book?
>> The original. Oh yes.
>> So all of these books are Islamic
scriptures, correct?
>> Yes. The original. Sure.
>> And these original Islamic scriptures
got corrupted. Correct.
>> The original ones got corrupted by man
to make space for the Quran to come and
give
>> Got it. So So, so basically it was
Allah's will for these scriptures to be
corrupted to make space for the Quran.
>> No, we as humans have free will and
humans like you guys corrupted the
books. Brother, why did you why did you
why did you just say no to what you just
said? I repeated you word for word what
you just said and then you said no to
it.
>> What did you say?
>> No, no, no. You should be asking what
did you say? You didn't you don't
remember what you said.
>> I I said the Quran came as the final
message. So now you said other books.
>> That's not what you said.
>> Are you
final?
>> That's not what you said. Did you not
did you not say that the previous
scriptures were corrupted to make space
for the Quran as the final revelation?
Did is that not what you said?
>> Yeah, I said the original message got
corrupted.
>> Allah willed for the previous scriptures
to be corrupted to make space for the
Quran because if the Torah, Psalms, and
Gospel were preserved and authoritative,
there would be no need for the Quran. So
Allah said, "You know what I'm going to
do? I'm going to send these scriptures,
but I'm going to have them be corrupted
so that there's room for the Quran to
come.
>> So trustworthy. Very trustworthy.
>> Would you believe in a religion with
corrupted scripture?
>> That's kind of a dumb question.
>> Well, can you answer the dumb question?
>> It's so
>> Is the Ail still corrupted today?
>> Yes.
>> So you still have corrupted scripture in
your religion?
>> It's no longer a part of our religion.
>> It is part of your religion. It's just
corrupted. You have corrupted part of
it's been corrupted. It's no longer part
of their religion. The way if somebody's
belief is corrupted how it works can
take them out of the fold. That's not
how it works.
>> Yes, it is how it works.
>> All right, cool. Find me Muhammad in the
jail.
>> Why does Muhammad need to be in the
jail?
>> Cuz your Quran says he is.
>> Uh give proof.
>> Chapter 7 verse 157.
>> Can you read it out?
>> Those who follow the unlettered prophet
whom they find written with them in the
Torah and the Inil. Obviously, I don't
have the verse, but I I know for a fact
that if you took two seconds to research
one of my scholars giving a verse where
Muhammad is mentioned, it's
>> No, I don't have
>> I'm not asking you to give me the exact
verse. What is the source that he's
going to
>> the Torah?
>> So, we still have the Torah today.
>> No.
>> So, then why would your scholar be still
going be going to the Torah if we don't
have it? If he didn't have it, how is he
going to the Torah?
And he said, "Why does he need why does
that need to
>> Huh?
>> You don't have it and it's not part of
your religion anymore. So what are they
going to? It shouldn't be nothing they
should go they can go to.
>> It doesn't need to be a part of their
religion to go to it for a one certain
topic."
>> What? Hold on. I got confused.
>> The the Torah you're saying was
corrupted and is therefore no longer
part of the religion. Yet your scholars
are still going to the Torah to find
Muhammad mentioned in there like their
Quran says he would. that they can. So
that means that the Torah they're going
to is part of the religion still that
contains Allah's revelation, right?
>> Give me the Wait, can you give me the
verse again?
>> Yeah, I'll give you the verse. I I'll
give you Go find the freaking stage,
man. Somebody said Brandon said Allah
one and four. He putting up Shaq
numbers.
>> Would you put Shaq at the free throw if
it's if it's if it's for the game for
the series? Absolutely not. Is is Shaq
trustworthy at the free throw line? If
he one and four, if he won for four,
man, would you trust him?
>> According to the according to the
Muslims, he is. They put Shaq at the
line every time.
>> Every time, man.
>> They only trust.
>> They They only tr they only trust that
one free throw he made.
>> That one. Hey, Shaq made it once, so he
trustworthy, man. We could trust him
every time he go through the line. He
good.
>> The mother the mother three free throws
he shot, he he didn't shoot anymore.
Would you would you would you trust the
religion with corrupted scripture, Mo?
>> No.
>> Did Allah reveal the Torah, Gospel, and
Psalms?
>> Yes.
>> Did they get corrupted?
>> You quick with it, too.
>> No.
>> The Torah, Gospel, and Psalms did not
get corrupted.
>> No.
>> Awesome. So, that means that the Torah,
Gospel, and Psalms are still intact to
this day. Yeah.
>> Uh, incorrect.
>> I can't do I ain't going to lie, bro.
This can't be four guests in a row, bro.
Come on, bro. What? Muslims, please,
please stop, bro. Four guests in a row.
>> In all of the other books, Allah never
said that the that they couldn't be
corrupted. In this book,
>> but he does he does say that no one can
change his words. Right?
>> He says that in the Quran, nobody could
change his words.
>> He doesn't say in the Quran, he just
says no one can change his words.
Period. He says none among all creation
can change his words. When he says
nobody could change his words, he means
that you you still can. But if you do
change his words, it's it's a sin.
>> Wait, wait, wait. Think about it.
>> Wait, wait. I'm thinking about it.
You're saying when he says blatantly
that no one can change his words, what
he means is is that people can change
his words.
>> Is that what he really means when he
says no one can do it? He means the
opposite of what he's saying. You got
you got to you got to think about this.
You feel me? If we're being honest and
we take the Quran for what it says,
Allah says no one can change his words.
The Torah are the words of Allah, right?
At least they used to be, right? The the
Psalms, the Gospel, these were all
Allah's words at one point in time,
right?
>> Correct.
>> That means none of them can be changed
cuz none of Allah's words can be
changed. But but if they were changed
then that means that Allah is
untrustworthy and he did not tell the
truth when he said none of his words can
be changed.